[Music]
do you consider yourself the Patriot
I love this country with all my mind
welcome to see
if your country needed you to lie to
your friends your family your life would
you do it I will be Empire working for
the government if your country asks you
to risk your life would you do it this
is the opportunity for me to give you
the life that I promised you nothing
my name my name is coming
I mean Sabbath a Shaykh is your only way
in please join me you've made a nice
life for yourself here in Damascus when
you walk into a room everyone wants a
piece of you come in enjoy you can trust
me with your life I hope I can do the
same we all have secrets or you added
another I'm worried about you when's the
last time you saw me
I don't want to go back you are saving
lives and they remember that
when I first became commonly be just an
accent you mumble in your sleep
you thought that sort of names
those nightmares that the shoes talking
about the nautical mind their comments
honest conversation all of my husband
does thinking of the clothes he doesn't
work anymore
I can't pull him away come out is
that life isn't real you are elite :
under that
it's a bit late for that
[Music]
[Music]